[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle denis robert c'est
un presque mi temps on vaut carrément
pas de l'art i had you ning je m'appelle
tel film sa marque
je suis là ma main denis
maintenant en ce moment une semaine
c'est plus relax au début du confinement
ont suivi le raid qui font couler
beaucoup beaucoup à celui de l'école en
français de l'anglais démarre plastique
puis le reste c'est essayer d'aller leur
maximum quand la température le permet
m'appelle monic gallant institutrice à
la retraite et grand maman de lily
écrire la france doit se rappeler deux
choses le comme la baisse s'est faite
avec la lettre z ou le s qui est placé
comment tu me l'avais bien nièce et mais
le mali entre deux voyelles bas il faut
mettre du lsc delphine que fait la
suggestion on a convenu que ça se ferait
tous les vendredis les cousins s'amuse à
lancer des coussins elle salue permet de
voir lily du coup les grands parents de
la petite fille forcément emilio sinon
ça fait un moment qu'il y ait deux
sabots oblige à me rafraîchir la mémoire
alors ça éloigne n'oublie et non s
reçoit aix 6.1 crime unit les macbook
quoi comprend genou alors un époux
thomas mythique kinect mais toi je
réponds à ma voix nul parce que c'est
beaucoup ce que cet écureuil
ça fait du bien de voir comment moi plus
cacher des moments où dans l'ensemble ma
prof d'art il m'appelait faire un usage
avec nos doigts et avec un morceau de
carton ce sera le thème paysages
regardez le thème magique et ça c'est
les crée
congés c'est eux qui prenaient congé
oui c'est difficile est ce que peut-être
le jeu tournait son formidable
magnifique qui n'est pas énorme mais sur
des jeunes de trouver paris cerveau or
metge
j'essaie de trouver du positif donc
j'apprends aussi je découvre je m'endors
part je la regarde à prendre des
vacances à l'école on me parle moi ta
dictée voir dans l'écran c'est cool j
ville de fautes
ce serait bête lutter si j'aurai tout
mal je suis très fier de valider
franchement je pense qu'elle peut très
bien réussir mais il va falloir qu'ils
apprennent à aimer toutes les matières
[Musique]
super
il me dit pas ce point un programme qui
chamboulera pas ce qu'est un peu les
corriger ce comme ce qu'on a
[Musique]